la question semble paradoxal puisqu'il
semble évident que nos réflexions aux
images souvenirs peut-être même le plus
précieux de notre être se trouve dedans
en effet la vie intérieure c'est ce que
nous expérimentons lorsque nous
détournons du rapport au dehors choses
extérieures et que dans quelque sorte
comme lorsqu'on ferme les yeux on
cherche à se retrouver
2dans loin de ses échanges avec les
autres déconnecté des réseaux sociaux
éventuellement dans des pratiques comme
la méditation ou le yoga
non nous avons tendance à penser cette
vie intime
par opposition avec l'extérieur
alors qu'en fait il ne s'agit que d'une
métaphore en effet il ya bien une
frontière entre l'intérieur et
l'extérieur c'est la peau mais si vous
ouvrez la peau vous découvrirez des
organes et rien de nos mondes intérieurs
donc il ya là une métaphore qui est une
manière de mal dire mal d'écrire quelque
chose qui est peut-être même mal
contenue il vaut la peine de réfléchir
pour essayer peut-être de corriger la
manière dont nous nous référons à ce qui
est le plus précieux
en fait cette différence entre vie
intérieure vie extérieure révèle la
différence entre le monde des objets et
ce qui est objectif et le monde des
sujets et ce qui est subjectif en fait
cette différence est historiquement et
métaphysiquement liés au développement
des sciences modernes qui sont fondés
sur la réalité objective alors qu'est ce
qu'un objet on pourrait dire qu'un objet
est défini par un certain nombre de
propriétés et d' usage en l'occurrence
une sphère bleue qui est utilisé pour se
passer les nerfs
en réunissant les propriétés et les
usages on obtient une vision cohérente
qui nous permet de constituer un objet
de ce point de vue les objets sont les
produits d'interaction entre des
protocoles d'expérimentation et des
descriptions très précises qui sont les
méthodes même de la science
d'un certain point de vue la réalité
objective ne préexiste non plus bas à
l'étude scientifique elle est plutôt le
produit de l'interaction entre méthodes
scientifiques et la réalité des choses
un petit peu comme la lune en fait et
éclairée seulement d'un seul côté par le
sol et la face lumineuse de la lune est
celle qui fait face au soleil de la même
manière un objet c'est ce qui dans les
choses est offert aux regards
scientifique
en définitive la réalité objective elle
même n'est pas ce qui préexiste à la
science elle est plutôt ce qui est
produit par l'interaction entre la
science ces protocoles et je dirais le
chaos des choses alors bien sûr en se
rapportant choses sur le mode de
l'objectivité
on découvre un très grand nombre
davantage on peut mesurer découper
assembler compose et décompose et les
choses à partir du moment où l'on
établit avec elle un rapport objectif
en revanche une grande partie de la
réalité devient problématique des
sensations des émotions le rôle
symbolique des choses le rapport au
langage tout cela en fait bascule dans
ce qui n'est pas objectif
et pour cause c'est le propre de la
subjectivité la subjectivité humaine
c'est évident n'est pas par des filets
s'ils ont une donnée objective au
contraire elle et ceux qui échappent à
cette tentative d'objectiver le monde et
qui du coup se constitue progressivement
à partir de pratiques ou l'autonomie
d'un certain âge en le sujet émergent
progressivement
alors lorsque les cette subjectivité
intime rencontre l'objectivité des
sciences modernes une frontière n'est
qui est la frontière entre l'intérieur
et l'extérieur
la conviction qu'il ya une différence
radicale est en réalité une réaction
étrange liés de la rencontre entre des
pratiques d'intimité de construction
subjective et de l'autre des pratiques
d'objectivité et d'élaboration
scientifique
dans ce contexte nos contemporains ont
fini par associer la construction
subjective avec des stratégies de repli
en fait c'est lorsqu'on se replient vers
soi lorsque l'on prend du temps pour soi
et pas pour les autres
lorsque l'on est seul et pas avec les
autres que l'on pourrait en quelque
sorte se retrouve cette attitude qui est
en fait un peu comparable à celle des
cloportes qui se referme pourrait donner
naissance à une société de cloportes si
elle n'avait pas deux inconvénients
le premier c'est qu'elle incite les
individus à s'éloigner des activités
collectives et des projets fait en
commun mais si l'on renonce aux actions
concertées
il n'y a plus de société possible donc
d'un certain point de vue je dirais
l'idéalisation du repli sur soi met en
danger les fondements même d'une société
possible d'un autre côté
l'individu lui même n'a rien à gagner à
concevoir les choses de cette manière
pourquoi parce que si nous sommes seuls
dans mon monde intérieur
nous sommes donc privé à la fois de la
reconnaissance des autres mais aussi de
la comparaison qui permet d'établir des
critères de valeur mais sans critère de
valeur sans possibilités de validation
sans même possibilité d'évaluation le
sujet se trouve complètement perdu il
entre en crise doute de lui-même ne sait
plus qui il est et n'a plus aucune issue
or du doute
il devient incapable d'être le sujet
d'une vérité et donc se trouve comme une
sorte d'exception à l'intérieur d'un
monde d'objets et vaut la peine de
reconcevoir les choses et je dirais de
surmonter cette métaphore pour repenser
nos pratiques de subjectivation celles
par lesquelles nous naissons comme sujet
alors il me semble qu'il est possible de
décrire la vie subjective d'une manière
plus précise
où en est reconnaissant des interactions
complexes
prenons un exemple comme un poème un
poème en général ne vous apporte pas
d'information nouvelle en revanche il
s'agit d'un travail sur une langue en
particulier et sur le langage en général
qui rend perceptible
le rapport de chacun a sa propre langue
et avec les autres locuteur qui
contribuent eux aussi à la modifier à la
faire évoluer
ali faire des expérimentations face
auquel le poète est peut-être celui qui
je dirais arrive le mieux à faire
partager ses innovations dans ce
contexte un poème fait percevoir
non seulement je dirais une subjectivité
à l'heure mais surtout le monde des
règles de monde puisqu'il utilise les
ressources du langage des ressources
inexplorées dans ce sens d'un poésie
comme beaucoup d'autres pratiques sont
des manières d'explorer des méta monde
des mondes qui se trouve comment sur
plan par rapport au monde de la réalité
subjective on pourrait dire en
définitive qu'à chaque fois que nous
faisons quelque chose comme par exemple
si je malaxe cette boule beaucoup
d'autres choses se passent en même temps
non seulement dans le monde
objectif il ya des mouvements que l'on
peut décrire mais il ya aussi des
perceptions que je ressens et qui me
sont propres
et il ya aussi des symboles comme
lorsque vous voyez un être humain
maltraité une petite boule bleue et
toutes ses diverses dimensions d'un acte
on pourrait les comparer en quelques
sortes à des couleurs une bulle de savon
par exemple c'est un objet qui a toutes
les couleurs à la fois c'est ce qu'on
appelle un objet iridescent eh bien on
pourrait dire que d'une certaine manière
les mondes des interactions se trouve
dans la même situation ils coexistent au
même moment
bien qu'il soit hétérogènes ils sont
comme autant de couleurs qui se
retrouvent sur les mêmes choses à la
fois toutes les choses du monde sujet et
objet sont des êtres iridescent alors
sur ses bases on comprend que nos monde
d'interactions ne sont pas intérieur il
ne se trouve pas logé à l'intérieur de
soi au dedans de la peau certains sont
perceptibles
certains sont totalement abstrait
certains peuvent être décrits par les
mathématiques
d'autres ne peuvent être accessibles car
la poésie
certains sont visibles par un seul
individu
d'autres n'apparaissent qu'à ceux qui
étudient des phénomènes qui se déploie
sur plusieurs siècles et parfois sur des
milliards d'années si l'on rassemble
tous ces mondes on n'obtient pas la
réalité objective celle inverse la
réalité objective n'est qu'une toute
petite partie d'une réalité beaucoup
plus grande
la réalité avec un grand r la réalité
que j'appelle
iridescentes dans ce contexte je ne vous
incite pas à abandonner vos pratiques de
repli je vous incite pas à mener votre
vie intime d'une manière ou d'une autre
fait que comme vous comme bon vous
semble en revanche je voudrais insister
sur le fait que ces mondes intérieurs et
ses pratiques subjective ne sont jamais
isolée par définition elles sont des
manières d'explorer des méta monde c'est
à dire de vivre sa vie je dirais dans le
nom objets et le nom objet c'est quelque
chose qui n'a ni dedans ni de 1
c'est important pour apprendre à référé
sa propre existence à des interactions
plus grande que soit même plus grande
que l'individu il me semble que dans le
monde aujourd'hui confronté à une
urgence écologique majeure il est
essentiel que chacun sorte de
l'impuissance volontaires pour
comprendre que nous avons à réparer des
liens qui se trouve dans un grand nombre
de ces mondes iridescent en revenant
vers ces interactions en travaillant sur
la subtilité avec laquelle nous sommes
reliés les uns aux autres
reliés à des choses qui ne sont pas
seulement des recteurs objective votre
génération la mienne et les générations
suivantes pourront travailler de nouveau
à explorer les naissances car il ya
beaucoup de meta monde à réparer